[Music]
this belief in the nothingness of
necessity and in the underworld becomes
belief
in heaven because the departed self must
unite with its universality
must explicate in this universality what
it contains
and thus become clear to itself
this kingdom of faith however we saw
unfold its content only in the element
of thought without the concrete notion
and for that reason perish in its fate
that is in the religion
of the enlightenment in this religion
the supersensible beyond of the
understanding is reinstated but
in such a way that self-consciousness
remains satisfied in this world
and the supersensible empty beyond which
is neither to be known
nor feared it knows neither as a self
nor as a power
paragraph 675 continues this
exposition on hegel's part
recapping the previous discussions
of religion now we're looking just at
the spirit
section of the work and we're actually
looking in this paragraph at the the
middle
portion which is quite long the culture
section which was broken into the
self-alienated spirit which then ended
up talking about faith right
and the section that we call the
enlightenment which then feeds
into the morality section
after uh freedom and the terror so
we've got a lot going on in those
sections but hegel addresses this you
know he's he's really eager to get
into the religion section proper so he's
not going to dwell
on the many paragraphs in which he he
discussed
this so he says this belief in the
nothingness of necessity
and in the underworld okay that was in
the ethical order right the
nothingness of necessity fate right all
of
all of that sort of stuff that was as he
talked about a universal that doesn't
have a self
and then we do have selves in the
religion
of the underworld or the religion of the
the dead who we acknowledge
love keep with us but in the previous
passage he just said listen you don't
you don't have the kind of
universality and agency that you need
there either
for a genuine religion in the sense that
hegel is going to
spell out here so that's going to give
way as we move into the
culture section the belief in this
the glaube right the faith in that
is going to give way to a different kind
of belief
what kind of belief belief in heaven
and we could say that that is
in some respect a throwback to
the unhappy consciousness couldn't we
but that's not what he says here instead
he says
listen in the self-alienated spirit part
where we are talking about faith
and it's it's opposition uh to
to various different things in the
dialectic
that faith becomes a belief in heaven
and within heaven how do we picture it
to ourselves
this is where you know a little
digression could be useful
i've often said to my classes if you
think about heaven the way that
that it gets depicted in cartoons it
looks like an incredibly boring place
that
really nobody would want to go to except
for people who are
are desperate for living on or people
who really like
sitting around in clouds with harps and
you know wings and halos and all that
other sort of sort of
accoutrements i was going to say
nonsense but you know
maybe some people believe in that sort
of thing
heaven can be understood in much more
robust ways
and in you know in christianity
which is really what hegel is focusing
on here in the west
depictions of heaven really were quite
well worked out
you could think of you know dante's
divine comedy as an example or all the
great iconography of the divine liturgy
taking
place in heaven or all these depictions
within
writings of theologians about what
heaven is going to be like they're
they're none of that namby pamby stuff
it's all a depiction
of being with other people
and and being able to truly be with
other people you know where your wills
aren't
contradicting each other because you're
all willing
you know things that are harmonious so
he says here the departed
self must unite with its universality
must explicate in this universality what
it contains
and thus become clear to itself that is
a
very very different conception of
life after death and a religious
orientation towards
the beloved dead than what we had in the
underworld hegel calls this a
nothingness a knicks right heaven
is something where now as we see here
he says the departed self
explicates what it contains and becomes
clear to itself it it realizes
what it is so that's an advance there is
something going on there
then he says this kingdom of faith
however we saw unfold its content
only in the element of thought without
the concrete notion
there's still something at least for
hegel
not well worked out enough about this
notion of heaven
and the development or freedom of the
self
within heaven and
what you know is actually going on there
there's something
missing in the picture and so we get
like he says
um it perishes in its own fate
that is in the religion of the
enlightenment and you know
we often depict us to ourselves the
enlightenment as a time
where we turned against religion
right you know and there is this
struggle of enlightenment with
superstition
that's not the same thing as as ruling
out religion altogether the
the enlightenment really did have its
own religion
and you know very often this was phrased
in
in terms of a deism you know you've got
a creator god
who sets everything in motion in terms
of the physical elements and the cosmos
but also inscribes a moral law within
the very framework or fabric
not only of the universe but of the
human being
you know kant's uh um you know
religion within the limits of reason
alone would be a prime example of this
but so would
uh thomas payne's the age of reason
which is a tract on dayism
you know so it's so many other
things like that and that that's you
know a viable
option for people at a certain point in
time now what happens with that shift
so hegel says in this religion in the
religion of the enlightenment
the supersensible beyond of the
understanding is reinstated so we're
going back now a couple
paragraphs to talking about this super
sensible beyond right um
but here something's kind of interesting
so
he's actually kind of blurring two
things together we have the super
sensible this is
referring back to paragraph 673 the
eternal
whatever else it may be is devoid of
self right and then we had the beyond
but where was the beyond in the unhappy
consciousness where there was
now self creeping in so he says the the
super sensible beyond is reinstated
but there's a key difference here
in such a way that self-consciousness
remains satisfied in
this world so all of these religious
themes about transformation about
attaining heaven they become part of the
driving force
of the enlightenment and the idea is we
can do it
here we don't need to displace it
off to some future that may never come
or
something beyond death and so he says
this super sensible
empty beyond which is neither to be
known nor feared
it knows neither as a self nor as a
power
so something gets left out that was
traditionally there
and now the enlightenment says that's
that's just nonsense that's
don't worry about that we're gonna have
a positive conception
of what heaven could look like the
kingdom of heaven here on earth
we're going to build it ourselves as
we've seen that doesn't really
actually happen and despite you know
humankind's best efforts to realize it
and so you know at the end of this
paragraph
we're left with this empty beyond which
is now
not really being recognized as an
important part of the process
in the religion of morality the fact
that absolute being is a positive
content is at last again recognized but
the content is bound up with the
negativity of the enlightenment
it is a being that is at the same time
taken back
into the self in which it remains shut
up and a differentiated content
whose parts are just as immediately
negated as they are produced the fate
however which engulfs this contradictory
movement is the self
which is conscious of itself as the fate
of what is essential
and actually
paragraph 676 is continuing this
progression
down what we can call memory lane of the
phenomenology of spirit
where religion has been partially
developed it's played a role in the
phenomenology
and the dialectic and now we're talking
about the
you know the third part of the spirit
section of the work the largest portion
of the work we're looking at the
religion of morality what has been
attained from hegel's perspective
in all of those back and forth
developments and discussions so he says
in the religion of morality we have
something
recognized what is being recognized the
fact that
absolute being phase in here is a
positive content now we should pause for
a second what does that mean
absolute being is a positive content
well
okay so religion is dealing with the
ultimate the
the eternal the you know um
super sensible whatever it's going to be
something pretty damn important
and what does it mean for it to be we
can talk about having
a positive content but here he doesn't
just say it has a positive content
it is a positive content what does that
mean
that means that it is manifested for us
in something that is not super sensible
something that we
can not just visualize
but tangibly encounter
and that's because it's us it's it's us
and the society
that we're in that's being taken as the
object right so it has a positive
content but then he says
it's also bound up with the
negativity of the enlightenment okay so
what's the negativity of the
enlightenment well there was a danger
in the enlightenment that it was just
going to engage in
critique you know going back to
earlier discussion in the phenomenology
where
faith is encountering enlightenment and
losing in the process because it's being
construed as
superstition the enlightenment does a
good job and
looks very good to people attracted to
it
and also to itself when it has an
enemy when it has something to critique
and that critique can very easily
spill back upon itself and
lead to a kind of perfectionism within
this world the more dangerous
perfectionism
as we've seen than that of traditional
religious perfectionism right that's
part of the negativity
of the enlightenment it's kind of it's
continually moving forward
but what is it moving forward into what
is it developing
so we have this polarity between
negative and positive here right
he goes on and he says it's a being that
is at the same time taken back into the
self
in which it remains shut up and a
differentiated content whose parts are
just as immediately negated
as they are produced well that sounds
pretty bad then doesn't it right
so there's this constant churning of
new ideas being proposed new ways of
doing things
and at the same time people are looking
for
something they can really latch onto
right
and here's where we get to the end of it
where there's a really very interesting
discussion
here about fate the fate
which engulfs this contradictory
movement now he actually doesn't say it
engulfs the
contradictory movement rather the
contradictory movement
sinks into that fate
sinks into that destiny whatever that
happens to be and now that fate itself
is getting a
kind of a positive content right because
in the past right fate was selfless fate
was just what it was and it confronted
us like something
alien and now we get to understand that
no we are the not just pawns of fate
or even agents of fate we are the agents
producing the faint and that
puts a terrible responsibility upon our
shoulders right
so he says the fate which engulfs this
contradictory
movement is the self
which is conscious of itself as the fate
of what is essential and actual and you
know what is essential in actual you
could just say essentiality and
actuality vason height and vehicle
kite these are somehow being brought
together here
and usually we only get one and we don't
get the other right you get vase in
height but then you don't get vehicle
kite essentiality without actuality you
get actuality without essentiality
here we're getting both and it's through
a self that is
conscious of its own involvement
in this process as what is producing
and then living out that fate
the self-knowing spirit is in religion
immediately its own
pure self-consciousness those forms of
it which have been considered
that is the true spirit the
self-alienated spirit
and the spirit that is certain of itself
together constitutes spirit
in its consciousness which confronting
its world
does not recognize itself therein
but in conscience it brings itself as
well as its objective world in general
into subjection as also its picture
thinking and its specific notions
and is now a self-consciousness that
communes with its own
self in this spirit conceived as object
has for itself the significance of being
the universal spirit
that contains within itself all essence
and all
actuality yet it is not in the form of
free actuality
or the apparent independence of nature
true
it has a shape or the form of being in
that it is the object of its
consciousness
but because in religion consciousness is
posited essentially in the determination
of self-consciousness
the shape is perfectly transparent to
itself and the reality it contains is
shut up in it and superseded in it
just the same way as when we speak of
all reality
it is universal reality as thought
paragraph 677 carries us
to the very end of the morality section
the
final part of it conscience
and hegel tells us what has been
achieved in that and you know when you
read this paragraph
it's a little bit hard to map that onto
those you know twists and turns and
final paragraphs of the conscience
section but
we'll we'll see what we can do with it
anyway so he tells us the
self-knowing spirit is
in religion immediately its own
pure self-consciousness right so we've
had this
self-knowing spirit and now in this
religion
section it's supposed to be a pure
self-consciousness a now does what does
that mean is it a self-consciousness
that's
pure by being decoupled from
other self-consciousnesses that can't be
the case because we know that
self-consciousness
has to exist in relation to other
self-consciousnesses
so maybe the purity lies in its relation
to itself well
let's go on so he says the forms
of it which have been considered and
then he
says okay the true spirit meaning the
ethical spirit right the early part of
the spirit section
the self-alienated spirit in which we
saw all of this
development going on with
thought and faith and the enlightenment
and
all of that sort of uh thing culminating
in freedom and the terror
and then finally the spirit that is
certain of itself these three
are all he says constituting spirit in
its consciousness
now constituting spirit in its
consciousness
they're sort of summer summing up what
are the possibilities for spirit as well
as
showing us a development and what's
key to all of them what is different
about the
conscience shape of consciousness
is that they are all oriented towards
their they confront he says
a world now this is
not a world that's simply a natural
environment as in say observing reason
it is a humanized world a social world
a world of others and a world
in which it doesn't as he says the
spirit in its consciousness does not
recognize itself
in that world now the word that he's
using for that miller's translating here
is recognize
is air cannon right it's not on air
cannon it's just the word that we use
for like i
i know that i recognize that song i
recognize this road that we're going
down so it doesn't
recognize it doesn't know who it is
in that world it doesn't recognize its
own contribution
to the situation that it's it's
confronting
so he says in conscience
moving you know into this final
progression and stage you could say
shape of consciousness in conscience it
brings itself
as well as its objective world in
general
gegensten like belts right so it's got a
different relation to the world
it's bringing the world and itself
now into something into what
into subjection as well as
its picture thinking and its specific
notions now isn't that a weird thing to
say
so it's bringing itself and the world
into subjection
and these two different
modes of communication thinking
articulation
picture thinking for stellang right and
specific notions he's using the word big
if there right so
um notions that have been
made the notions that have been
specified
that have been made particular bezondrus
right
so it's doing an
awful lot isn't it this this conscience
and it's understanding itself in a
different way and he says it is now a
self-consciousness that communes with
its own self
where did we see that in in the
conscience
section did we really see it communing
with its own
self i guess by the end we did
and he does talk about god in that
respect right
but we've been mostly dealing with these
dualities and and
uh antithesis running throughout that
that section
so he goes on and he says in this
in what in how conscience is bringing
all these things into subjection
spirit conceived as object has for
itself the significance of being
now here he talks about the universal
spirit that contains within itself all
essence
vase and height and all actuality
virtually kite now and they said
something really important here so
if it contains all essence in actuality
that sounds like it is totalizing it it
actually should be absolute spirit not
just universal spirit
shouldn't it we we're talking about
absolute spirit just a little bit
earlier in the
end of the uh morality section
and in the beginning of this section
weren't we
but it's universal spirit there's
something that's actually not being
realized here
it may contain or extend to
or try to dominate all essence in
actuality
but it doesn't actually do so right
why not because there's a certain kind
of
actuality that is not being taken into
account here he says it is not in the
form of
what free actuality and then he says
or the apparent independence
of nature it's lacking something
even if it seems to extend and it
doesn't
clearly extend to all essence in
actuality
insofar as it's not yet free it doesn't
so he goes on and he says true it has
shape or the form of being in that it is
the object of its consciousness right
its
conscience this this reconciled
uh harmonized you know
reciprocally recognizing polarity that
we saw in the end
it has that is the object of its
consciousness and then
hegel says but because in religion
consciousness is
posited essentially in the determination
of
self-consciousness the shape is
perfectly transparent to itself
and the reality it contains is shut up
in it
and superseded in it just as the same
way as when we speak of all reality
well what does that mean when we talk
about all reality
this is you know in a way we could think
about this in in
going beyond hegel we could think of
this in a heideggerian way
heidegger tells us at a number of points
we're never grasping the totality of
being
it just doesn't happen except through
something like mood
right with hegel he says no no we can we
can grasp it
we can't grasp it as actuality
we can grasp it in a different mode
universal reality
as thought if it's mere
thought though that's a that's a bit of
a problem isn't it
in the hegelian dialectic we always see
at least in the phenomenology that if
something is just a thought
it's not yet what it needs to be notions
even might be underdeveloped or not
fully realized
they they attain that through our action
in the world our comportment
our relations to others and so now
you could ask well what what does all
this have to do with
religion really is bringing us to the
end of this
you know short discussion of all the
places where religion has popped up
before
and why those however interesting and
illuminating they've been
are not precisely what he's what he's
going to be discussing
in the passages yet to come where he's
doing the positive development you know
not not too far from this just a few
pages after this
he is actually going to get us into
natural religion right the first
set of new dialectics and
so do we do we get that from the
previous developments in
self-consciousness spirit no we're not
we're not getting that
yet but we will see these developments
soon and so we're kind of meandering
into figuring out well what the hell is
religion then
you know we thought we knew what it was
now we have to kind of
you know expand the notion unpack it
let it develop be good phenomenologist
you know see what's going on
we were doing something kind of like
that in conscience but we
only grasped it in a certain way
and as thought so we don't
yet have the religion that we're seeking
you